[Music]
I love Instagram story ads now why like
targeted ads they have nothing to do
with me yeah I like record them every
time really well let's see if I can pull
one up I got like an ASMR plug come on
man quick before the mods get here you
want Gable your amrap mine still are
like weirdly targeted like I actually
think that sometimes when I'm looking at
them I'm like how the [ __ ] I thought I
turned tracking and I thought you were
[ __ ] you know I thought Facebook
didn't do this [ __ ] anymore right what
are some of yours I don't know it's like
I
I don't know odd guys dancing to Noah
back I think that I mean I'll just tell
you some personal [ __ ] okay like part of
the reason why I'm going to therapy is
because I think like my relationship
with alcohol is probably not as healthy
as it should be and so one of the ads
that came up on my thing today
it's for a liver pill that promotes
liver function and immune system Health
they both really work but I kept
forgetting to take them so now I keep
them next to my toothbrush just in case
good thing too because when you forget
we all pay for the next game
literally it's cool when they know that
right yeah yeah how the [ __ ] oh I I said
nothing I did nothing I emailed a
therapist that's all I did yeah isn't
that [ __ ] crazy it freaks me out what
else am I doing
um that has the same patterns as someone
that would need a liver pill well on
that note there was a joke I was like
telling the shows but I stopped because
I think it was hard for people to really
really giggle at uh in that same vein
um I got I would get targeted ads for
anti-suicide and I got one for a
revolver gun lock first we want to show
our viewers that this firearm is
unloaded and has been fully cleared
yeah it was meant for like War veterans
oh my oh my God I know my whole bit was
um I was like well I'm a smart ass so
all I did was sit through the whole ad
and I was like oh I just won't use a gun
yeah can't lock up rope
oh God
that's my fiance gonna do leave the
house and take all the chairs with her
come on Jesus Christ
yeah I know but yeah see you're laughing
[ __ ] I'm just thinking you make that
joke on stage and then Instagram gives
you an ad for like a I don't know
a smooth house
with no furniture yeah just concrete
walls like this
a smooth house
no edges nothing to hang anything on
90 foot ceilings
no I feel like they'd be like uh you
know they started giving me like ladies
yeah Kanye's house exactly they're
giving me like ladder advertisements
yeah those discounts yeah bungee cord oh
you're saying they'd be doubling down
yeah well now the thing is like I guess
like it's
ethically fine to give those ads because
it's I don't know it's it feels [ __ ]
weird right it's definitely weird
because because I mean there was that
story early on with Facebook targeting
and when everyone's talking about all
that stuff when they were basically
targeting women for pregnancy stuff
before the women even knew they were
pregnant because of their browsing
habits ooh because they were like you
know they were looking up morning
sickness and just stuff that had to do
with pregnancy yeah and so all of a
sudden Facebook would start like
advertising like baby cribs to them and
stuff like that and they're like what
the [ __ ] is this and then they would
take a pregnancy test and find out
they're pregnant so Facebook knew before
they knew and so like it's just like I
don't know there's just this whole
when it comes to stuff like this there's
just this really dark
yeah I'm undertone to the whole thing
yeah [ __ ] well when I got that ad I was
just laughing like maybe this is not the
one to get in the mix on like of all the
things to suggest yeah rather than a
therapy service
they think that you're that far gone
yeah well maybe you know this gun lock
will help yeah the thing that made me
laugh about that was the ad was telling
you to put the lock in and then there's
a key that goes into the chamber it's
like a it's like a looped lock so it it
like goes through one of the chambers
and then comes back around and you lock
it with a key and they advise you to
give that key to a loved one how psycho
is that to have that key like to go up
to someone and be like hey
this is so I don't blow my brains out
it's crazy yeah that's pretty wild yeah
now you're rethinking that Batman
criticism aren't you guys
yeah so
um
anyways yeah
um I'm really trying to find this ad it
was so weird oh here it is
that combined
what
it's an ASMR helpline for people that
are suicide yeah like literally Man
endle sound what is that